dylan cease is the white sox starter he
went four and two thirds against the
angels in his first go around allowed
three runs on five hits walk three cade
three
now the switch hitting carlos santana
all for four
in the series opener on his 35th
birthday he is all for his last 12.
now you'll see a lot of umpires set up
toward the inside corner check swing on
a pitch in the dirt he went around
santana strikes out
two punch outs in the first for cease
the royals do not score the sox are
coming up mike miner the royal starter
this afternoon he throws left-handed the
white sox have won 17 straight games
against lefty hurlers dating back to
last season switch hitting leori garcia
will lead it off the all 405 braves hold
the record that's 18 in a row
minor nudge yes to the sign
brings the pitch breaking ball swung on
and missed
nicely located slider
and michael a taylor is the batter
the 3-1
missed another high one and now they've
got dozier caught and he's going to be
out for some reason dozier got too big a
secondary lead collins threw behind him
and nailed him at second base and the
royals are done
in the second inning garcia struck out
in the first
batting right-handed
here's the 3-2 pitch
went right after him lined to center
field and caught
by whitmerfield before it got to center
field
so miner gets out of trouble
he gave up a line drive to get out of
the inning
mercedes who walked in the second
the american league player of the week
in the short week
that was the first few days of the
season but what a
opening
he had to the season there's a breaking
ball grounded a third hunter dozier has
it he'll fire across the first
and after a lead-off double and a man at
third with one out mike miner pitches
out of it and keeps this game scoreless
as we go to the fourth then and the
batter is jorge soler
the set and the 3-2 a swing and a miss
he got him on a slider
he's got five strikeouts worked around a
couple of walks here in the fourth
garcia with two on and two out fourth
inning
sox trying to break the seal here and
get the first runs
two and two to garcia
line over third it's a fair ball
the sox will take the lead
by a one it's an rbi double
madrigal home and laori garcia comes
through
with a two-strike double
leary garcia makes it one-nothing white
sox in the fourth
and two more in scoring position
luis robert
high and deep into left field but it's
going to be playable for ben and tendy
and he makes the play
the white sox have already stranded
seven today but here in the fourth they
have scored for the first time we go to
the fifth is we'll have it one nothing
chicago
standard defensive alignment against
dozier
2-2 serve swing and a miss strike three
cease has six strikeouts
he brought that's nacho cheese right
there 98 miles an hour
right by him
and now
a dangerous batter two on two out for
mirrorfield
ball in the gap could make it a 2-1 game
with the royals leading currently they
trailed one nothing here's the pitch a
swing and a shot to left that's a base
hit here comes kyle isbell here's the
throw to the plate offline
and the royals have tied it on the base
hit by merrifield
it's a 1-1 ball game as witt drives in
his 10th run this year man he is a tough
out
two outs a run in two on
and the batter is
left-handed hitting andrew benintendi
kopeck from the stretch
2-0 is rolled to the second baseman
madrigal who scoops throws and gets him
the royals have tied it up
on the merrifield rbi hit we go to the
last of the fifth
and now two on with two out and the
battle will be
zach collins
collins was an all-american at the
university of miami a high draft choice
moving into the white sox
as a backup catcher to yasmani grandal
getting the start today barlow deals
fastball lifted in the air should be
played either taylor or isbell michael
with the call in the catch
and the chicago white sox leave two more
they have left nine stranded through
five
royals one white sox won
hunter dozier leads off the seventh
inning
to short oh danny mendick go get you one
mickey played his college baseball in
omaha at creighton university
it was a star shortstop there
bummer deals
and that is just barely off the plate so
lopez with a good plate appearance he
walks
[Applause]
andrew o for two a strikeout and a
ground out he walked in between
let's see if he can shoot one down that
left field line here's the pitch
checks his swing in a fastball end
and lopez breaking on the pitch
steals second base without a throw
lopez stole second
now the 2-1 pitch to ben and tendy swung
on hit to the left side and through
that's a base hit here comes lopez he
will score and the royals take a two to
one lead and that's ben and tendy's
first rbi as a royal
adam eaton has grabbed a bat
for andrew vaughan
williams the runner at first here's the
pitch
eaton into the right field corner it's
deep it is gone
to run homer
adam
[Applause]
nobody out
[Music]
[Applause]
santana
did he apply the tag now he throws it
away
collins goes to third madrigal goes to
second base
and now they're going to get a call it
looks like from the home plate umpire
todd tishner
that
madrigal is out
well i think he maybe he was out of the
baseline
first and third two outs for robert
next pitch knocked up the middle and
caught by whit merrifield
a fine catch but a two-run home run by
chicago's adam eaton has given the white
sox a 3-2 lead
carlos santana will bat
white sox will over shift to the right
against him
santana hits it well to center
robert is back he's all the way back and
the game is tied you got him carlos
santana picked a perfect spot
to get his
first hit of this road trip
and one blown save turns into another
blown save and the game is tied at three
in the ninth inning yes the matter will
be andrew benintendi who drove in a run
back in the eighth inning with a basin
he's going to square the bun he's going
to drag about right side of the pitcher
he throws home he gets away from the
catcher taylor scores and the royals
take the lead here in the 10th inning
second and third two down now
for carlos santana
popped him up
fouled territory it's a catcher
collins near the plate to make the catch
so
the royals do
convert as they get that free base
runner the sox will have a similar
situation as we go to the bottom of the
tent it's now 4-3 kansas city
so now it's up to nick madrigal
two out runner at second
last chance to dance for the sox here in
the 10th
zimmer from the bell
here's the 0-1
swing grounder to short nikki lopez has
it fires to first in the royals win
the royals come from behind force extra
innings and the royals beat the white
sox in 10 innings 4-3